so basically for the past year I've been
living with my girlfriend after her
mom's her mom's um we've been working
you know our both of our salary jobs and
then an extra job on the side
um save as much as we can and now we've
gotten to the point where I think we
have enough to kind of you know buy our
first home no no no no no no no no don't
do that
no no never buy a house for someone
you're not married to
okay under any circumstances you're
about to get yourself in a huge mess
yeah you complicate the breakup like
nothing like nobody's business you're
gonna buy a house with her you better
put a ring on it first buddy I know
that's right yeah that's kind of that's
kind of the first thing right now
because we've been we've been together
for about six years now come on painter
get off the ladder I know that's right
Beyonce taught us better than that put a
ring on it I know I know I know but it's
like I don't because if we get married
right now you know that's you know a lot
of money that we got to spend on the
wedding and they're buying a house
I know you're already sleeping together